créer son activité c'est une bonne idée
de devenir son propre patron mais
pourquoi ne pas reprendre une entreprise
s moins risqués excuse est plus simple
nous allons le voir avec nos invités
dominique boissonneault donc délégué ile
de france ouest de l'association cédants
et repreneurs d'affaires et jean marie
michaud chef d'entreprise dans le
transport attrape on va commencer par
présenter le ces rajustements cédants et
repreneurs d'affaires association
nationale depuis 1985 200 bénévoles
fédérés anciens dirigeants patrons
d'entreprises le siège est à paris 70
délégations régionales dont la vôtre ile
de france ouest quel est son but
véritablement c'est aider mettre en
relation cédants et repreneurs tout à
fait l'association accès de son briquet
s'occupe de mettre en relation des
vendeurs une entreprise et des
repreneurs et nous sommes positionnés
sur le créneau effectivement de la
petite et moyenne entreprise plutôt
petit que moyenne à 10 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires et des
valorisations entre 300000 et 4 à 5
millions d'euros
pourquoi est ce si difficile de mettre
en relation les cédants et les
repreneurs
ces demandes ont l'impression que c'est
logique ils vont se mettre en relation
de même norris possible
ça n'est pas toujours utilisables le
monde des vendeurs notamment intermondes
discret il ya un gros souci de
confidentialité parce qu'une entreprise
qui change de mains ça entraîne souvent
des conséquences et le dirigeant fait
très attention à ne pas ébruiter la
cession pour que tout se passe avant que
ce le bruit circule avant que
l'information circule la cram c'est quoi
c'est de voir que l'autre on imagine en
tout cas que l'entreprise se porte mal
son passe la main que qu'elle est faible
sur le marché face à ses concurrents
peut-être pas que le nom mais un
changement de direction dans une
entreprise peut amener des fournisseurs
à se poser des questions des clients qui
se disent au changement de dirigeant
changement de méthode
changement tactique donc on peut attirer
de ce fait des comportements et pour
et clients et fournisseurs qui risquent
de se tourner vers d'autres prestataires
par souci de sécurité remplir votre
association vous permettait la mise en
relation et que les choses se fassent
sereinement sans inquiétude en tout cas
dans la plus grande confidentialité en
tout cas effectivement et nous avons
effectivement beaucoup beaucoup de
repreneurs mille quatre cent mille 500
en permanence et entreprises alors sur
le marché parce que vous parlez de
beaucoup de repreneurs potentiels mais
combien sur ce créneau d'entreprises
faisant quand de quoi on parle sur deux
créneaux d'entreprise c'est-à-dire
petits commerces et petit artisanat
exclu mais le début vraiment des
entreprises en 3 et 10 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires sait on est à peu
près tous d'accord sur avec les
professionnels du marché 5 à 6000
affaires par an qui change de mains bon
on vous sert à on en traite à peu près
450 cas tu es nous avons effectivement
en permanence 5 entre 500 et 600
affaires en stock permanent en face d'un
portefeuille de repreneurs personnes
physiques très majoritairement 2500
candidats jean marie michaud aux chefs
d'entreprises donc vous avez repris la
société que vous dirigez depuis quand
quel est votre depuis novembre 2006
d'accord alors comment vous êtes
positionnés pourquoi avoir fait ce choix
de la reprise d'entreprise parce que je
voulais changer de vie
on expliquera peut-être pourquoi ce que
j'avais fait avant 1 donc je voulais
changer de vie je voulais donc être
dirigeant et indépendants surtout un
désir d'indépendance une motivation
indépendance importante et donc j'ai
voulu effectivement reprendre
l'entreprise
et pourquoi ne pas créer tout simplement
de partir de zéro créé l'entreprise vous
fera marcher j'ai repris et deux ans
après j'ai créé aussi l'entreprise à
côté donc mon entreprise et 10 litres
ensuite aux touristes de transport de
marchandises spécialisée dans le coeur
métier c'est la course urgente et deux
ans après j'ai cru entendre une
entreprise de transport de personne
puisque j'avais parmi mes mes clients
beaucoup de grandes entreprises qui
avaient des cadres dirigeants qu'ils y
qui voyageait et donc j'ai donc proposé
à ses cadres de les transporter
également aux aéroports différents
rendez vous il était facile de reprendre
l'entreprise trouver celle qui vous
convenait alors c'est toujours un un
parcours du combattant
avec beaucoup d'obstacles et des
obstacles souvent invisible c'est et
donc il faut je pense qu'il est très
important de bien se préparer et pour se
préparer
bon moi j'avais un syndrome de davantage
parce que j'ai fait une une formation de
gestion finance donc cette partie là je
la possède et bien j'ai dirigé
des équipes donc cette partie là je la
possède est bien aussi j'avais fait de
la fusion acquisition donc cette partie
l'aja diriger je la connaissais un petit
je connaissais même bien mais surtout
pour les grandes entreprises
donc une pme comme les et dominique
c'est complètement différent
et en plus les vendeurs sont discrets
donc c'est un marché de cash est bon
donc il faut aller chercher le marché
caché donc ça c'est des premières
difficultés qu'il faut surmonter et pour
pouvoir les surmonter il faut pas partir
la fleur au fusil comme ça il faut se
préparer et donc il faut seulement se
mettre en mode projet moi j'avais
travaillé beaucoup sur la dernière
partie de ma carrière en entreprise sur
des grands projets financiers
internationaux et donc je me suis dit
j'ai pris un petit peu de recul et j'ai
dit voilà je veux être en mode projet je
vais travailler c'est un vrai projet que
j'ai c'est un projet de vie c'est aussi
un projet de reprise d'entreprise cetera
il ya une chose qui me manquait c'était
justement le mode le monde de la pme que
je ne connaissais pas et surtout la
psychologie du cédant que je ne
connaissais pas non plus donc le marché
de la fusion acquisition oui négocier à
la wii les data room
oui c'est des grosses boîtes pour les
pme c'est complètement différent donc en
fait j'ai fait une formation non pas ça
lui sert à une d une des fonctions du
crr aussi aussi de faire de la formation
vous accompagne tout à fait et donc moi
j'ai fait de lui une formation s'appelle
cinq jours pour reprendre qui organisé
par les chambres de commerce et ce qui
m'intéressait effectivement c'était le
début de la formation et la fin de la
formation au mieux c'était la partie
gestion financés terrain valorisations
bon et là notamment la fin c'était le
début c'était comment approcher le
marché la pme et la fin d'information
c'était une fois vous avez découvert
l'entreprise que
qui vous intéressent comment aborder le
sujet avec le cédant voilà donc c'est ça
moi qui me manquait que et que donc j'ai
appris parce que modestement il faut
apprendre on change de métier
le dirigeant l'entreprise d'une pme
vraiment on change de métier car mettre
en relation les cédants et les
repreneurs c'est difficile c'est
notamment le but de votre association il
ya aussi eu des forums quelquefois qui
sont organisées la chambre des métiers
de l'artisanat des yvelines on
organisait un récemment à versailles un
forum sur la reprise et la transmission
d'entreprise nous y étions valérie
auribeau alice gastines et patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les images
cédants et repreneurs le réclamait la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat des
yvelines a fait un premier forum de
reprise d'entreprise se tenait à
versailles lundi dernier afin que chacun
puisse se rencontrer et échanger
on s'aperçut qu'il y avait 40% des
entreprises dont dirigeants allaient
partir à la retraite dans les prochaines
années
on s'est dit qu'il fallait quand même
s'occuper de ça et faire prendre
conscience au cédant qu'une transmission
ça se prépare ça se prépare souvent cinq
ans avance dans l'idéal même plus
parfois certains secteurs d'activité
accuse un déficit de repreneurs c'est le
cas de la boucherie qui enregistre peu
de candidats dès la formation et donc
peu de salariés et d'éventuels
repreneurs
après du marché trop élevé peut aussi
effrayé les futurs acquéreurs sur place
avocats et experts-comptables démêler
les imbroglios juridiques car nos
transmissions d'activité peut s'avérer
complexe
beaucoup de facteurs qui rentrent en
ligne de compte et l'activité
commerciale aujourd'hui est très
difficile donc avec les nouvelles
réformes qui sont instaurés aujourd'hui
wilb d'amour évidemment il est très très
très difficile de savoir quelque chose
de définitif que la reprise s'est faite
dans une totale harmonie parce qu'on
s'est bien entendu avec les ceux qui ont
cédé qui nous ont aussi bien conseillés
pour pour l avenir nous bien évidemment
on a écouté leurs conseils on n'a pas
voulu non plus tout révolutionner parce
que je pense que c'est pas la chose à
faire quand on arrive il faut savoir
faire perdurer ce qui était déjà là
avant ensuite on est petit à petit sa
patte personnelle ses produits et puis
mais voilà tout s'est extrêmement bien
passé au total une centaine d'inscrits
participé à ce premier forum
les annonces des entreprises a cédé
exposé lors du forum sont à retrouver
sur le site internet de la chambre des
métiers
ce qu'on a pu voir avec ce reportage
sait aussi que le nombre d'entreprises
qui sont mises en vente sur le marché
c'est un chiffre un nombre qui va
augmenter de plus en plus dans les
prochaines années
j'entendais un ticket en plus de plus en
plus de ses dents parce que les chefs
d'entreprise vieillissent et veulent
passer la main c'est pas sûr on nous
annonçait ya trois quatre ans un boom
effectivement en raison du papy boom
tout simplement ça veut dire une
génération d'entrepreneurs qui arrivent
à l'âge de la retraite on l'a pas
complètement vue parce que les
conditions du marché ont changé entre
temps la crise est passée par là
certaines entreprises ont disparu
certains vendeurs se sont dits dans ces
conditions je vais vendre dans nous mal
vieux concerne mon entreprise et il faut
dire que la génération aussi des chefs
d'entreprise qui arrivent à l'âge de la
retraite la retraite ça n'est plus 60
ans et 61 62 103 autres cartes et des
alentours et quelque peu
70 ans on en trouve encore aujourd'hui
sur le marché économique justement
regard de la crise c'est la meilleure
des solutions de reprendre une
entreprise ça assure déjà quelque chose
de plus solide que de se lancer dans une
entreprise tout neuf a monté de a à z
oui y'a que des avantages les
inconvénients bon jean marie bien
illustrer la chose je pense la reprise
permet quand même de monter dans un
train qui fonctionne déjà
on prend les commandes on prend la suite
du sauveur et le train continue de
marcher une création il faut partir de
zéro
donc il ya un temps d'inertie et avant
de vivre sur l'entreprise qu'on a créé
il faut souvent un an deux ans trois ans
alors que là le train comprend braff qui
permet aux chefs d'entreprise et à tout
son personnel mais quand tu cèdes entre
deux visites sur justement que
l'entreprise est viable n'est pas en
difficulté ça aussi ça fait partie de
vos missions vous assurer ce travail là
oui alors nous l'assurons pas forcément
direct nous avons un réseau où après
avoir parlé qui qui peut conseiller et
aider nos repreneur
dans dans leurs démarches c'est le
réseau qui intervient pour savoir si
l'entreprise est viable fiable en tout
cas oui quel jeu joue justement parce
que vous en parler mais alors le réseau
il se compose effectivement de des
délégués du cera que nous sommes nous ne
sommes pas des marchands d'entreprise
mais nous les 200 délégués ont tous une
expérience entreprises au minimum voire
entrepreneuriale puisque nous avons une
bonne partie de nos délégués qui sont
des anciens chefs d'entreprises eux
mêmes et leurs émissions excusez moi
vous avez repris votre entreprise
voudrais juste savoir vous étiez sûrs
qu'elle était viable fiable qui avait
pas de souci ah oui tout à fait parce
que en fait lorsque d'abord ça va ça
vient lorsque lorsqu'on choisit les
cibles que l'on veut identifier et est
donc en identifiant les cibles pendant
que l'on veut que l'on qui nous
intéresse on se renseigne sur les
entreprises bien évidemment et avant de
reprendre
il y a tout un process
dès le moment où on signe une une
promesse d'achat et de vente s'engage
ainsi nombre de vérifications des audits
savoir si le prix qu'on va payer pour
l'entreprise et elle bon voilà on dit
comptable audit social voilà et donc est
généralement les promesses telles
qu'elles sont faites sont sous réserve
que effectivement il n'ya pas de
découvertes qui sont révélés par par ces
audits comme quand on achète un
appartement en fait on est sûr attention
alors qu'elle vient d'abandonner alors
bon un entrepreneur il c'était quelqu'un
qui prend des risques donc on n'est
jamais sûr de rien non mais il faut il
faut déjà c'est vrai que la reprise est
un petit peu plus facile encore que ça
dépend qu'une création pure bon il des
avantages et inconvénients à l'est de
mai donc et pays avant tout il faut
avoir l'esprit entrepreneurial et donc
faut être prêt à prendre des risques et
les risques calculés et bien évidemment
mais il faut les prendre on peut pas se
se border complètement même partout les
audits possible bon alors il peut y
avoir toujours des choses qui on a on
prend un risque par exemple
effectivement de moi qui le dis c'est
pas tellement les fournisseurs mais
c'est plutôt les clients lorsqu'une
entreprise change de mains effectivement
il faut tout de suite rassuré les
clients donc on en parlera peut-être
dans les prochaines phases de due
process
mais la phase d'accompagnement
du cédant et éminemment importante dans
ce cadre là bas nous restait finalement
assez peu de temps alors juste pour
conclure j'aimerais qu'on s'intéresse
aux missions aux objectifs de cédants et
repreneurs d'affaires donc que vous
représentez ce soir vous formez vous
accompagne et vous suivez ensuite oui
vous êtes la bombe est présent à toutes
les étapes j'ai tout à fait c'est ce qui
complètent leur réseau qu'on avait
commencé à évoquer
nous avons effectivement un institut de
formation c'est la formation qui est une
filiale de l'association et qui elle est
une société commerciale qui assure donc
une vraie prestation de service c'est la
préparation de nouveaux repreneurs qui
sont très majoritairement des personnes
physiques cadres de l'entreprise qui
sont sur le marché de l'emploi ou
volontairement qui ont une démarche de
rations de l'entreprise donc le but
c'est de les mettre tout de suite en
condition de recherche de leur expliquer
comment est structuré le marché ou est
ce qu'on trouve comment on négocie comme
on analyse les précautions à prendre les
dangers de l'opération le montage
financier l'opération jusqu'à la
signature de l'acquisition de
l'entreprise
le film est déroulé pendant un stage de
trois semaines qui est assez costaud et
qui est devenu quasiment un label
aujourd'hui sur le marché un label de
comme un diplôme de capacité à reprendre
et nos partenaires extérieurs puisque
nous avons aussi les partenaires les
banques notamment pour aider nos
repreneur à trouver des financements
il ne s'y trompe pas quand ils voient
venir
candidat serra qui a fait la formation
il dit voilà quelqu'un de motivé et qui
sait de quoi il va parler hier justement
si vous voulez plus d'information sur le
cr a donc l'association des cédants et
repreneurs d'affaires il ya un site
internet il s'est affiché et vous pouvez
avoir toutes les informations merci pour
être venu sur ce plateau merci de votre
témoignage également à jean marie
michaud chef d'entreprise dans le
transport sur trappe